calcula la pendiente de la línea que
pasa por los puntos 7 menos 1 y menos 3
menos uno por acá voy a hacer una
gráfica para poder visualizar dónde
están estos puntos y por dónde pasar la
línea recta así que déjenme dibujo aquí
mis ejes ahí están y bueno nuestro
primer punto es el 7 menos 1 así que 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 en mi eje x
y menos uno en la dirección de ahí está
el 7 menos 1
este es mi declaró
y en mi segundo punto es el menos tres
menos uno así que me voy tres unidades a
la izquierda retrocedo tres unidades y
mi coordenada ya es de nuevo menos 1 ahí
está y la línea que conecta estos dos
puntos se ve algo así
ahí más o menos el ejercicio nos pide
encontrar la pendiente de la línea que
pasa por estos dos puntos es decir de
esta línea de aquí intuitivamente la
pendiente es una medida de lo inclinada
que está una recta aunque más
formalmente la pendiente está definida
como el alza entre el avance o lo que es
lo mismo el cambio y entre el cambio en
x y en algunos casos la pendiente
aparece denotada por la letra m
el cambio aparece como de 2 que es la
coordenada y el segundo punto menos la
coordenada del primer punto y 1 dividido
entre el cambio en x que es x 2 - x 1 en
realidad todas estas fórmulas son
expresiones distintas de la misma cosa y
al significar la pendiente es el
siguiente si me alzó mucho en dirección
y al avanzar poco en dirección x la
pendiente va a ser un número muy grande
si por el contrario me alzó un poco en
relación a un avance en x entonces la
pendiente es un número chico que es más
o menos lo que sucede aquí en general
podríamos emplear cualquiera de los dos
puntos como nuestro punto inicial pero
en este caso vamos a empezar en el menos
tres menos uno así que me voy a mover
del menos 3 - 1 al 7 menos 1 mi
coordenada x empieza haciendo menos 3 y
termina siendo 7 positivo por acá así
que hay un cambio de 10 unidades se
mueve desde menos 3 a 7
entonces mi cambio en x 10 y cuánto es
muy cambio en g
pues acá vale menos uno pero acá también
vale menos uno así que realmente no
cambie en la dirección de mi cambio y
vale cero así que en este caso el alza
es cero no importa cuánto me mueva
millet se mantiene igual para calcular
la pendiente dividió el alza entre el
avance nuestro avance fue de 10 unidades
muy bien y parece cambio en x cuánto
vale mi alza pues mi alza vale 0 así que
la pendiente es cero
otra forma de pensarlo es que esta línea
no tiene inclinación es completamente
horizontal así que en este caso la
pendiente es cero bien y ahora vamos a
ver que esto coincide con todas las
fórmulas recuerdan que todas las
fórmulas equivalen a el alza entre el
avance o lo que es lo mismo el cambio
entre el cambio en x lo importante es
que todas son una medida de qué tan
inclinada está una línea recta pero
bueno si empleamos la fórmula la
pendiente m
tomando el 7 menos 1 como nuestro punto
inicial y el menos 3 - 1 como nuestro
punto final y en este caso x 1 7 y 1 es
menos uno menos 3 sería x 2 y menos 1
sería de 2 así que este es nuestro punto
inicial y este es nuestro punto final
así que la pendiente vale el cambio en y
que es de 2 menos de 1 que es menos 1
menos -1 dividido entre entre x2 que es
menos 3 - x 1 que es 7 así que tengo
menos uno menos menos uno que es menos
uno más uno dividido entre menos tres
menos siete que es menos 10
de nuevo esto nos da 0 entre menos 10
que ya sabemos que nos da 0 la razón
para que aquí aparezca un -10 y acá un
día es positivo se debe a que
intercambiamos nuestro punto de inicio
en nuestro punto final es decir aquí
habíamos empezado en el menos 3 -1 y nos
habíamos movido al 7 menos 1 en el
segundo ejemplo lo que hicimos fue
empezar en el 7 menos 1 y movernos al
menos tres menos uno entonces en este
caso en el segundo ejemplo nuestro
cambio en x es negativo porque nos
movemos a la izquierda pero nuestro
cambio en 10 sigue siendo 0 así que el
valor de la pendiente 0 pues es una
línea horizontal